[Music]
it's a common saying that elephants
never forget
but these magnificent animals are more
than giant walking hard drives the more
we learn about elephants the more it
appears that their impressive memory is
only one aspect of an incredible
intelligence that makes them some of the
most social creative and benevolent
creatures on earth
unlike many proverbs the one about
elephant memory is scientifically
accurate elephants know every member in
their herd able to recognize as many as
thirty companions by sight or smell this
is a great help when migrating or
encountering other potentially hostile
elephants they also remember and
distinguish particular cues that signal
danger and can recall important
locations long after their last visit
but it's the memories unrelated to
survival that are the most fascinating
elephants remember not only their herd
companions but other creatures who have
made a strong impression on them in one
case - circus elephants that had briefly
performed together rejoiced when
crossing paths 23 years later
this recognition isn't limited to others
of their species elephants have also
recognized humans they've bonded with
after decades apart all of this shows
that elephant memory goes beyond
responses to stimuli looking inside
their heads we can see why the elephant
boasts the largest brain of any land
mammal as well as an impressive
encephalization quotient this is the
size of the brain relative to what we'd
expect for an animal's body size and the
elephant's EQ is nearly as high as a
chimpanzees and despite the distant
relation convergent evolution has made
it remarkably similar to the human brain
with as many neurons and synapses any
highly developed hippocampus and
cerebral cortex
it is the hippocampus strongly
associated with emotion that aids
recollection by encoding important
experiences into long-term memories the
ability to distinguish this importance
makes elephant memory a complex and
adaptable faculty beyond a rote
memorization it's what allows elephants
who survived a drought in their youth to
recognize its warning signs and
adulthood
which is why clans with older matriarch
s-- have higher survival rates
unfortunately it's also what makes
elephants one of the few non-human
animals to suffer from post-traumatic
stress disorder the cerebral cortex on
the other hand enables problem solving
which elephants display in many creative
ways they also tackle problems
cooperatively sometimes even outwitting
the researchers and manipulating their
partners and they've grasped basic
arithmetic keeping track of the relative
amounts of fruit in two baskets after
multiple changes the rare combination of
memory and problem solving can explain
some of elephants most clever behaviors
but it doesn't explain some of the
things we're just beginning to learn
about their mental lives
elephants communicate using everything
from body signals and vocalizations to
infrasound rumbles that can be heard
kilometres away and their understanding
of syntax suggests that they have their
own language and grammar this sense of
language may even go beyond simple
communication
elephants create art by carefully
choosing and combining different colors
and elements they can also recognize
twelve distinct tones of music and
recreate melodies and yes there is an
elephant band but perhaps the most
amazing thing about elephants is a
capacity even more important than
cleverness their sense of empathy
altruism and justice elephants are the
only non-human animals to mourn their
dead performing burial rituals and
returning to visit graves they have
shown concerned for other species as
well one working elephant refused to set
a log down into a hole where a dog was
sleeping while elephants encountering
injured humans have sometimes stood
guard and gently comforted them with
their trunk on the other hand elephant
attacks on human villages have usually
occurred right after massive poaching's
or callings suggesting deliberate
revenge when we consider all this
evidence along with the fact that
elephants are one of the few species who
can recognize themselves in a mirror
it's hard to escape the conclusion that
they are conscious intelligent and
emotional beings
unfortunately humanity's treatment of
elephants does not reflect this as they
continue to suffer from habitat
destruction in Asia ivory poaching in
Africa and mistreatment in captivity
worldwide given what we now know about
elephants and what they continue to
teach us about animal intelligence it is
more important than ever to ensure that
what the English poet John Donne
described as nature's great masterpiece
does not vanish from the world's canvas
you
[Music]